how's it going bros the name is pal I'm
wearing the same shirt is yesterday my
god let's keep playing what the [ __ ] did
you come from all right let's put the
memory in I hope one of the memories
gonna be a cake cuz I [ __ ] love cake
one it sounds terrible oh she must be so
worried about you
I made she doesn't even give a [ __ ]
don't patronize me
oh of course I need a [ __ ] hug do you
think I am I'm not Superman
I need hugs I guess so I didn't follow
you check fries should we see where it
takes all right
first I first I need a hug man it
doesn't hug me what is he talking about
it pugging
let the Heidegger
you like it all right here we go again
let's be careful what is this and light
the hell oh wow this looks cool what it
was going on here oh god is that bled oh
god the can i blood I'm a baby I
wouldn't even know the concept of what
that is I would probably just be like
that [ __ ] I wouldn't even know what [ __ ]
is except if it feels good in my butt
when I do it let's be honest that's what
they think okay
reading seriously I don't mean to be
rude but he really is this line
it's like bag what the hell is going on
here whoa that's kind of cool that's
pretty awesome so we open a crazy bridge
what awesome
get it get it get it get it get it get a
girl um too fat all right well I'll get
smoothies have to do the old-fashioned
way baby pack oh [ __ ]
top oops let me to do that
hey not perfect up here but sorry all
right let's go oh [ __ ] am i laughs Malev
that's right broom you can't kill me not
today broom no sir I'll go a picture
broom try harder next time you're never
gonna be on Ellen right sergeant ball
you make sure the broom doesn't do [ __ ]
don't like his attitude
Norah's outfit of the week god it was
like all black my god can we go in here
it feels like we can or that a crappy
man hello
what the [ __ ] it's beautiful I like it
I'll be teddy I love everyone I love
boots
hey boots are okay too and you won
Oh God [ __ ] everyone what what no not
him again
Oh God Oh what I'm definitely in you
[ __ ] what what is happening here you
better hug me
let's pay attention to the music and
everything shall be fine
that's me Japanese cookies I'll pass
thank you next year delicious
I'm just very full very full maybe we
can enter from here uh-oh what's with
these creepy pictures man ah that's a
hat very good all right sit fit no it's
a every way
right hug me [ __ ] I'm hugging you
[ __ ] hard man oh god oh god it's the
creeper coats again I don't like them
one bit
no sir don't dance for me coats don't
you that don't you day days for me coats
[ __ ] is dripping apron coats
dance trying to god is it him again
it is him again isn't it that's a sexy
pajamas man going for that dirty
hardcore I'm cool guy look this is a
Joey yo I'm pretty good at this look
yeah you see Wow ten out of ten would
Jojo again I need a key what kind of key
hold an object use right mouse button to
throw away was it will you yo yo yo yo
you don't you couldn't possibly fit in
there now no yo yo no my god do I have
any out Jim's maybe I need to throw it
on something to get it down yeah that
would make more sense okay let's see
here that looks good
go my alright well I'm not gonna be a
baseball er that's for sure oh god is
coming oh god is coming all right you
know what I don't have time for
breakfast or tea or whatever the [ __ ]
babies do I am going in here thank you
very very much for your hospitality it's
been a pleasure I am gonna go to Vegas
and gamble [ __ ] all right all my money
all my baby money all my napkins not a
puzzle so pretty this game I love there
the design it's cool you don't see this
[ __ ] I'll lead you actually a lot of
dream stuff is like this I can hear
mommy can well to get that sweet milk
what else what else would I want
seriously
scratching it's probably just deaf and
suffering don't worry about it now what
is that sound
what was that Oh what is he doing but I
need you I need you to not be stuck
right now so I can goddamnit basketball
l can't beliee
confused and lost and all alone okay I
guess we have to go and check the creepy
salon oh boy
hello the names put it PI I'm in Gaga
Google that old baby says I don't know I
don't I don't have not been hearing all
that baby I wouldn't know I don't take
notes either okay all right this looks
safe it's hard to me baby oh we just
need to move this yeah I don't I don't
know but they say her that's pretty
weird
aah aah I got it so maybe we should
throw these out that sound that that
makes it's pretty horrifying ketchup ha
cheap kind
yeah can I crawl in I don't think so but
let's write okay
ow don't do that in in Sweden the
ketchup brand is called Felix the most
famous one and everyone used to make fun
of me because the slogan up there no one
needs me funny because I beat the [ __ ]
out of them and no God what the [ __ ] uh
that's even creepier than the other one
hello Oh Jeb fly oh god oh god I'm so
sorry I'm just going fine Yolo well God
he's coming go go go go go ah come on
all right we did it whoa ah now don't
fall anyway what I was saying was and
the slogan was Felix makes the tasty
even tastier and then we're jingle Felix
makes it tasty tastier and then everyone
would say change it when they said it to
me and they would say Felix makes the
disgusting were disgusting here and I
heard this and why they would say that I
was just a little kid and I don't make
the Explorer disgusting act get Danny
okay I don't care oh it landed there
Jesus that didn't break
what the hell what come on no fun as a
baby allowed apparently oh there oh my
god I can't believe I did see it let's
throw this paper roll at it [ __ ]
okay don't worry I have this bread
container Schechter all right don't
worry I have a toaster I can throw the
toaster all right one two three
[ __ ] all right how about the frying pan
it's not a frying pan what whatever all
right I'm not very good at throwing the
frying pan what about the coffeemaker
all right tell us sir you're my only
Batman yes
toaster Oh God Oh God is he coming oh
god he's coming oh god oh god oh god I'm
heading oh god is he
hello don't hurt me please thank you oh
[ __ ]
all right food is good who likes to
dance - everyone likes a net there's
nothing weird about that so I got what
did I get a star oh yeah oh yeah I
remember now
was so long long long ago the level
design is so like I think it's kind of
hard to follow it's very pretty and very
cool but for me it's like why the [ __ ]
am i I don't know if that's a point or
not but I guess right now I'm supposed
to find my way back right but I don't
know how I'm just going with it it seems
to be working so far goes on my mind if
I can genius oh god oh god oh god all
right we need to go up there I think oh
yeah we need to go back oh what the hell
whether oh god she's yelling at us
goddammit it compares yell at you it's
the worst when they say your food gets
more disgusting here oops oh [ __ ] he
heard that he deaf Yolo
Oh God Oh God
I don't like this basketball cover mitt
oh [ __ ]
good job Wow ten start [ __ ] are you
doing
it goes like half scaring me in this
game I don't like dad no no no we've
been here oh you have a pendant now I
know oh god I'm gonna have to pass
through without making a single sound no
problem oh [ __ ]
alright easy now easy does it
alright I'm just gonna take you put you
down gently and I'm gonna take you put
you down gently I'm gonna take you put
you down gently and I'm gonna uh I'm the
best and the best don't meet on my hest
that's a horse in Swedish the only thing
that ran girl
Sargent basket you're doing it mighty
good job I'm supposed to check in here
that's a chair
alright I felt like that
what about in here oh we might not have
a choice actually [ __ ]
simmer down zip hug me hug me teddy
Oh God
now I just want to peek what deaf dark
why is everyone such a douche douche I
mean oh I didn't almost didn't see mr.
Buttle okay we're fine who placed all
these bottles no did that super glue is
good but that's abusive she'll never
abuse super glue all right you know what
you got a little oh god I should not
have done that
I really should oh oh [ __ ] me baby Acme
Acme hug me oh god don't ever note to
self don't ever do that again
god this game doesn't give you a break
much actually does give me a lot of
breaks I'm just a [ __ ] actually I'm a
baby get it yep
quality welcome to my channel quality
what do you think I have so many
subscribers could say what one quality
quality yokes
as in funny oh [ __ ] funny voices a lot
of swears and a lot of scares back we
did it
I feel so good right now is that a face
God ugly get off me all right I'm
putting you in
yeah yeah I got don't like the Mikey
[ __ ] what I'm the largest I know it's a
[ __ ] the whale is the largest animal
Wow way to educated me Mom all right
give me Gandalf we got final memory
let's hurry
we got to find a memory I don't know
what to write
now we're gonna go and party I hope and
the swag on alt I'm probably gonna die
but I gonna know
Oh God
what is this what's going on here all
right you know what no time for
investigating now mr. Watson we shall
have to go in beside that Oh
Holy Mother of penis no no no Kenny out
Teddy Teddy do the back ah what ah [ __ ]
what just happened what just happened
oh god it was supposed to happen it was
invalid
his arm I look like a cigar I want to
smoke I don't smoke okay well we have
Gandalf now I bet you [ __ ]
I don't even want to look at here okay
I'm gonna look at you and then I gotta
go away you you're on your own [ __ ] Wow
Thanks what is this not now let's give
what what does that mean I Love You Man
nice when I be with you
mom mom you never pay attention to me
is she an alcoholic
it's all these tiny white things she's a
nose eater
designed supposed to do that I don't
think I was supposed to
I'm in the lies I'm in the lines just
tore the pod
Oh Jeff not not aren't you me
if you
do it
so dark
I can't do it I can't do anything
hello
but there it is
okay what now
why a lot of mere memories man I I don't
even have weird fucked-up nightmares
like this like i i i dream gonna have
big booties
oh we're back we did it teddy oh no oh
that feels the feels doing it for you
teddy
what about me perhaps you only forgot
about you had me didn't you
you send him a [ __ ] bag hey I'm - I'm
not a slot okay all right I'm gonna have
to put you in there and roll all right
who's gonna press now we have is that's
bad man
and this game makes me sad man and go
I'm good guy I'm sorry if I've ever been
to you did we go in what lies beyond
this door only a baby can tell I hope
it's mama
I'm thirsty milk what it's more what can
dove can't afford back get enough we
made it and what we made it all right
where's teddy
there's the owl and their sergeant ball
and there's you I guess and what do you
want there's stary and there's boxy and
as the puzzle pieces why is it such a
mess though I don't remember this being
a mess
a kid's imagination and need them to
protect Asian as a powerful thing ah
this is weird man I'm springing canned
off with me in case because I don't have
Teddy right now and it may
oh god no more scarce man I don't want
any more I just want to know what's
going on at this point that's a puzzler
and there's a plan side we never saw but
you know then there's a fan oh god [ __ ]
this room uh-oh what's going on
mommy wait there get off honey she is an
alcoholic mommy it's it's okay
mommy why did you hurt me Mommy maybe
you shouldn't drink
oh I get it so they took a I took us
away from mom
it feels men it feels
that was a really good game I don't mind
that it was short I was a little like at
first I was I was worried that hey it's
gonna be short so it's not gonna be that
interesting but it was really good and I
like the story it was a good story or
whatever it wasn't that much of a story
but the whole idea I like buying it it
was pretty cool I like that and it's
very interesting cuz you didn't realize
right away but I like that Jesus is
these all the Kickstarter supporters got
a dad there's this many people working
on this yeah it's probably the
Kickstarter all right well I hope you
enjoyed this little tiny adventure with
me I had a lot of fun playing it and I
think you enjoyed watching it so thank
you for doing that it's almost fun to
share this with you bros I really enjoy
doing series of games I don't know if
you noticed I've been doing more lately
and because there's been more games
lately so thank you to krillbite
students for making this awesome game
thanks to all the people I've made this
game happen and thank you bros for
watching
maybe like a majority series I very much
appreciate it and I will see you in the
next thing we're gonna do dad summer us
love you